you know the confidence you personally
have to have to wear Sketchers on the
mountain how did that happen bro
Sketchers they have been awesome I was
underarmor my whole career they just
stopped making my cleat and so I had
enough for a few years after and I kept
trying new cleats of theirs in the
interim I was like man this just don't
feel right the guy that helps me out in
La his name is Bill he he reached out to
Sketchers and I said oh we can we can
make a cleat for him and sure enough
they did and like it felt amazing so you
going for youer trying look good I think
the spikes look great have you seen them
this year they look great the only time
I see your spikes when I go in the
training room on the day you pitch 20
tows behind you laying back sleep with
your shoes untied it's my nap time maybe
not a Jordan guy but a lot of guys out
there have been telling me that they
want to try him and there's been a
couple guys Wade Miley's wearing sketch
so we got some guys